Okay,
so I'm talking today with Dr Michael
Shermer and darker Schermer is among
other things the publisher of skeptic
magazine,
but more importantly for our purposes
today,
he is also the author of this book,
New Book and were heaven on Earth.
We're going to talk about this today in
some detail and so I'm going to turn
this over to Dr Sherman who's going to
tell you some things about himself and
then we're going to have a discussion,
is going to outline this book and then
we're going to have a discussion about
well,
why he wrote it and what it contains and
what the implications are and all of
that.
So over to you Michael Jordan.
Thank you for having me on the show.
It's.
Well,
the book is kind of an extension of my
previous work.
Most of my books when I write them,
they kind of push off from the previous
book,
so going all the way back to my first
white people believe were things which
was about the supernatural and
paranormal and and all that.
Then then that led to how we believe,
which was white people believe in God,
and then if you don't believe in the
supernatural and you don't believe in a
deity,
what about morality?
So I wrote two books on math and science
of good and evil and the moral,
our last book,
uh,
so then,
you know,
kind of covering all the big subjects,
uh,
from a skeptical,
scientific perspective.
The afterlife is obviously a huge one
and I haven't really dealt with that too
much in my previous books.
And you know,
now that I'm in my sixties,
I guess you could say I'm cramming for
the final
thinking about these big issues.
This is not something that I obsess
about it.
I'm not terrorized by death like,
like some people are,
but I think it's a super interesting
subject because it's obviously a part of
the human condition.
It's something people do think about.
And apparently we're the only species
that can do this.
Although I have a chapter in heavens on
earth,
on animals that grieve clearly.
Quite a few mammals do grieve and they
have some sense of loss,
death and grief,
you know,
for fellow group members or family
members that die,
but it's not clear that they understand
that their moral.
Um,
and then I,
you know,
I had covered the possibility that
neanderthals were self aware of their
mortality because of grave goods that
have been found,
although that's hard to fossil fossil
fossilization of bots is difficult to
interpret,
but it seems reasonable that they had
some sense of that.
But in any case,
uh,
so I,
I deal with the,
you know,
the,
the monotheisms versions of the
afterlife,
Heaven and mortality,
a Judaism,
Christianity,
Islam that mainly because you sort of
have to.
Although mine's a science book and those
are sort of low hanging fruit that
atheists have already kind of picked
that.
So I don't spend a lot of time on that.
I'm focused more on scientific attempts
to achieve and mortality and science.
So actually start with what does it seem
like a scientist,
Deepak Chopra,
worldview of sort of western Buddhism
that,
that there is the idea of birth,
death and afterlife.
Life before life is all kind of
meaningless because it's all
consciousness in a deep box worldview as
he puts it,
a,
you know,
consciousness is the ontological
primitive.
You can't get underneath it a,
you know,
the scientific attempt to explain it by
material means will always fail because
that's not where consciousness wise
anyway.
So I,
um,
thanks to my wife actually delved into
his world view,
Deepak and I have class for 20 years and
I've called his worldview woo and
pseudoscience and,
and you know,
we've been kind of at odds at each
other.
So as it changes,
he's sort of the main,
you might say,
intellectual force.
I don't think it's unreasonable to say
the main intellectual force behind the
new age movement or associated with the
new age movement.
Is that right?
Yeah,
certainly one of the most prominent
ones.
He's got a huge following.
He goes on Oprah and talks about these
things and Dr Oz or whoever and you
know,
he has a lot of following.
So,
um,
so my wife and I actually went down to
his center or center in Carlsbad,
California and spent some time there.
I get,
we delved into meditation and Yoga and
the tea and the chanting and all that
stuff just to kind of see what it's all
about.
And uh,
you know,
I think there's something there in terms
of behavioral change that is how it
affects your body and your mind and your
thinking.
And I could definitely see something to
that and um,
and,
but,
but also the difficult part that,
that feedback and I have had is the same
problem that most scientists have with a
new age beliefs but not just that,
but,
but of non western traditions that,
what Deepak calls the eastern wisdom
traditions that it's the language,
the difficulty of language.
We have to use words to communicate,
um,
and the words you use matter at some
level.
You have to be able to be talking on the
same level with words.
So when Deepak says,
you know,
the ontological primitive or
consciousness is the womb of creation,
you know,
these are,
it sounds sort of metaphorical.
And he means something very specific by
that.
If you can't get at that,
then you're wasting your time talking.
So I'm Deepak and I have kind of become
friends and we were constantly
communicating just to try to see if we
can find some ground where we're talking
on the same plane.
And so I think I've a learned a lot from
him in that,
in that sense.
And so my chapters devoted to him on
that and the general eastern wisdom
traditions,
you know that when you die,
because I always ask them,
well where do you go?
And he says the wrong question.
I mean,
you've just returned to where you were
before,
you know,
because when people ask me,
well,
what do you think happens after you die?
My standard kind of quip is the same
thing.
You go to the same place you were before
you were born.
What are you talking about?
I wasn't anywhere before I was born.
Right?
And you'll be nowhere after you die,
but for Deepak,
time and consciousness kind of overrides
the concept of time at the beginning of
your consciousness just returns to where
it was and that the physical body and
brain is just a temporary instantiation
of consciousness into physical be.
But it just goes back to some other
place and,
and near as I can figure,
we don't have the words to even conceive
of what that means.
Uh,
that is the western language,
the way scientists talk.
I can't really capture what he's talking
about in that sense.
And so that's why I think we kind of hit
an epistemological wall there where you
have to actually get into introspection,
meditation,
and that the deeper parts of that
tradition that I've never been able to
really get into personally.
So I can't say I understand it,
although I kind of see where he's coming
from in that regard.
So,
so let me ask you some questions about
that.
So the first might have to do with this
idea of the ontological primacy of
consciousness.
Say now,
one of the things I've learned from
studying mythology is that the
mythological worldview,
first of all,
I think the mythological worldview
conceptualizes the world as a place to
act rather than as a place of things.
So it's sort of like Steven g dot j Dot
Gould's idea of two magistarium don't
overlap.
There's a moral magistarium materialist
magistarium say,
but it's been striking to me,
looking at the architect will
foundations of mythological thinking
that in the in the scientific worldview,
there seemed to be two fundamental
causal elements.
You could say nature and nurture,
something like that or biology and
society,
and then technically sophisticated
western academics argue about the
relative contribution of each to any
given a existential phenomena.
But in the mythological worldview,
there's always three actors.
There's nature usually personified as
female or experienced as female because
personified isn't quite the right word.
There's culture,
but there's also the individual and the
individual seems to be the same thing as
the conscious actor and that would be
the hero,
the dragon slaying hero say,
and there's that.
There is a kind of primacy given to
that.
So in the oldest creation myths,
you always see this interplay between
the mother,
often mother earth and the father that
the sky and then the hero who separates
the two and somehow brings and
perversely in some sense,
although being their product clearly as
the offspring is also the thing that
gives rise to them mouth the same.
At the same time,
and it seems to be something that's in
keeping in some sense with our lived
experiences that we confront the social
world obviously,
and our beneficiaries and victims of it,
and we confront the natural world in the
same manner,
but we also seem to be a gentek actors
and without us as a Gentek actor is the
idea that there's a reality,
seems to,
it seems to be full of paradoxical holes
like reality without a conscious actor.
And I think that's the sort of statement
that,
that generates the thinking that you've
referred to as characteristic of,
of Deepak Chopra and the people who,
who make those sorts of claims.
So,
I mean,
what,
what's your,
what's your take on,
on consciousness and its role in being.
Well,
the one hand,
it's everything because it's what I tell
what I tell Deepak,
what I write about in that chapter is
that,
um,
you're familiar with the anthropic
principle.
So I call this the,
that the week consciousness principle
that without consciousness,
without consciousness,
nothing exists.
You know,
this is one of the points that he makes
for me.
And you personally,
if we're dead or we're not conscious,
the world doesn't exist for our brains,
it's gone.
Nothing.
There's nothing,
uh,
but,
but he goes further than that.
He says,
this is what I call the strong
consciousness principle,
that,
that consciousness has required.
Our consciousness is required for
material things to exist.
And so there I have a discussion of what
a Donald Hoffman,
the cognitive scientists at UC Irvine
calls is,
um,
uh,
the interface perception theory.
Uh,
I dunno if you're familiar with this,
but his analogy is like your laptop
screen here and you'd have these icons
on the screen,
like the little trashcan icon looks like
a trash can.
But of course there's no trash.
Get the open,
the open your laptop.
There's no trash can.
And there,
you know,
these are just kind of icons that
represent something that we think of as
a trash can.
And,
um,
you know,
this is,
gets to the problem of,
you know,
what it's like to be a bat,
a famous thought experiment,
you know,
if like bolted on some,
some huge years.
And I and I had an echolocation system
and the neural processes to process that
information and so on.
I would have some sense of what it's
like to be a vet,
but it had everything on to actually be
a bet that I would just be a bat and I
wouldn't even be,
I wouldn't even know I was a human
wondering what it's like to be a bad.
Okay.
So at some level we can't actually know,
um,
you know,
what it's like to be something else.
And so you,
again,
with Deepak and I and these kinds of
traditions like that,
we hit this system logical wall of
language.
It's difficult to say what you mean by
certain things.
Yes.
Especially when you get down to the
fundamentals of things.
Well,
it's pretty clear that the things that.
So let.
Let's look at that user interface idea.
So obviously what happens when you're
looking at a computer screen is that the
complexity of the screen is reduced to a
set of icons that can serve as tools.
Right?
And I think that that's a reasonable way
of thinking about how we look at the
world.
Is
Theory is that natural selection didn't
select our brains to,
to record an accurate representation of
reality,
like a scientific model will attempts to
get ever closer to what reality is
really like no natural selection just
wants us to escape predators.
It doesn't matter what they look like,
what the icon in your brain of breads
that spraying or whatever,
as long as you survive,
that's all that matters.
So this is why we're so easily deceived
by illusions and magic tricks and things
like that that,
you know,
our brains aren't really wired to,
to,
to represent reality as it really is,
whatever that means.
And
Yeah,
you can say that without human
consciousness,
the iconic reality that we inhabit would
not exist.
Right?
Okay.
Slightly is that is I told them.
So let's say,
you know,
what's it like to be adults in it?
I don't know.
Okay.
So some kind of echolocation system.
So,
and his point is,
well,
they're,
you know,
sharks are dangerous.
So,
uh,
his,
they avoid charts.
But the question is what does a shark
look like in a Dolphin's brain versus
what it looks like in our brain?
Um,
it's probably quite different and I
really have no idea what a shark looks
like,
two adults,
but I do know this,
there really are shirts and they really
have sharp things on one end and a tail
and the other and they're eating
machines and you should avoid them.
So yeah,
that's awesome.
So that's actually a weakness of the
icon claim I would say because it looks
to me like here's the twist on it,
what we see in our conscious experience,
our functional icons,
but they were also low resolution
representations of the things that are
actually there.
And I don't think that computer icons
are low resolution representations of
the things that are there.
They're just functional icons.
I might be wrong about that because
because it's hard to to conjure up that
analysis on the fly.
But the trash can,
for example,
on your desktop is actually,
it's actually a low resolution
representations of an actual trashcan,
not a computer trash even though it
functions the same way.
So I like the icon idea,
but I think it misses some element of
the actual relationship between the
perception and the reality.
We definitely see in low resolution,
which is why we can stand animated
pictures like say the simpsons,
you know,
where,
where everything is one extremely low
resolution,
but that makes no functional difference
to us whatsoever and we definitely see
and hear in low resolution,
but the resolution like what we see or
something like instead of icons,
they're more like thumbnails that are
functional.
That's a good analogy.
And then.
Well I like it because the thumbnail
thumbnail actually is an unbiased
sampling of the actual
object,
right?
Because a photograph is relatively
unbiased sample of an object and you can
compress it,
you can,
you can tell it and what you're doing is
blurring out distinctions between,
you're blurring out distinctions between
different aspects of it without,
without losing the relationship between
the parks.
It's something like that.
That's right.
And all.
And,
and in a way much of science operates at
a metaphorical level that string,
you know,
have you ever seen a string theory
documentary that didn't have violence
featured in it?
You know that,
that the compute,
that brain is like a computer.
It's like a dual processor.
It's like quantum information,
you know,
we can't because we have to talk and we
have to transfer the literal meaning of
metaphors to move something from here to
there in the original Greek.
So,
you know,
we're trying to capture some idea that's
really hard to get that buy something.
We're very familiar with some part of
the problem.
We had two that addresses some of the
issues you've dealt with,
with,
uh,
with some of your recent conversations
with people as we're operating at
different levels.
So with Deepak,
for example,
pounds me with articles about quantum
physics,
so you don't.
Material stuff is really just energy.
Atoms are mostly empty space and so
forth.
And you know,
this,
this table is actually mostly empty
space.
This is all true,
but we don't live at the quantum level
at the federal level where I'm sitting
in a chair and I'm not passing through
it because at that,
at this level,
you know,
it's not the same as the quantum level.
And I think making that distinction,
um,
you know,
helps clarify a lot of things.
So like when you talk about the truth to
be found in a biblical stories are,
or literary stories like dusty Eskie or,
or Shakespeare or whatever,
and a material scientist says,
well,
no,
I mean something different by truth.
It's not that one of you is right,
the other's wrong.
It's just that these are different
levels or different ways of talking
about.
Think about them as different tool kits.
You know that.
That's right.
Different toolkits.
Yeah.
Classic American pragmatist is that I
think of these things as tools.
There's a scientific tool kit and
there's a,
there's a tool kit for action in the
world and they overlap,
but they're not the same.
So for example,
I call this,
um,
elvis error,
alvie singer,
that character in woody Allen's film.
I'm Annie Hall.
And there's that funny scene where
there's a flashback that where he's in
childhood and he's refused to do his
homework and he's depressed and his
mother takes him to the doctor or
psychiatrist,
whoever he is.
And okay,
what,
why are you depressed?
Alberice is because I found out that the
universe is expanding.
So what?
Because if the universe is expanding and
then eventually it's all gonna blow up
and nothing means anything.
Other names,
Adam?
We live in Brooklyn.
Brooklyn's not expanding hallmark.
That's a nice observation I think too
because.
So.
Okay.
Let's go back to the conceptualization
issue.
So one of the things that we've agreed
on,
and I don't want to lose track of that
thread because I think it's useful is
that we do see an iconic reality and the
icons have practical utility,
but they also bear some one to one
correspondence with the thing in itself
and it's low resolution is a nice way of
thinking about.
So they're low resolution icons with
functional utility.
Now the question would be,
so then that makes clear is that without
human consciousness all that disappears.
Okay.
Then the question is partly what is
there outside of that functional iconic
representation and so that would be the
old question of the thing in itself and
you could say,
and I think you could say with some
justification that the thing in itself
is in potential something that collapses
across time and space so that it's
everything and nothing at the same time,
which is I guess that's an eastern
claim.
That's one way of thinking about it.
It's a Dallas claim and I like it
because the problem with the or one of
the issues that,
and this is associated with the idea of
Brooklyn.
It's not only does lb lb or lv lv.
Not only does healthy live in Brooklyn,
he lives in Brooklyn now,
right?
And so it's spatially located and
temporarily located and so his mother's
objection is,
well,
don't pick a reference point that makes
everything right now irrelevant,
which I.
which is really good practical
psychological advice because one of the
things that leads people down the path
of nihilism is this claim that this
observation that you can pick a time
frame of analysis that makes your
current action useless.
Who's going to care in a million years?
Right?
So that argues it,
you know,
without God,
without some sort of external source for
morality and meaning nothing,
nothing we do matters because in $15,
million years,
you know,
the heat death of the universe or
whatever,
we don't live 15 billion years from now,
we live now here.
And what we do does matter,
uh,
you know,
so thesis would argue,
the theodicy problem without God,
there's no right or wrong,
whatever Stalin did or Hitler did is
perfectly fine because of the heat death
of the universe.
No,
it's not fine because the people that
are suffering in the Gulag archipelago
or in the gas chambers at Auschwitz,
they're not thinking about 15 billion
years from now,
they're living right here and right now
the torture is really doing wrong by
these standards.
So again,
the level at which we're talking about
is everything.
And this is why in the heavens on earth
I,
I'm concerned about the obsession with
the people obsessing too much about the
afterlife.
Not just religious people,
but scientists.
So what I call it at the afterlife or
atheist,
this is the core of my book,
is really about all the cryonics people
in the transhumanists and the singular
Tarion's and the extropians and the,
and the people that are gonna Upload
your mind into a computer and turn it
off.
You know,
ray Kurzweil and all these guys,
you know,
they're,
they're almost gurus when you go to
these conferences,
you know,
it's like we get to live forever.
We are the generation that gets to live
for
some of them think they're the,
they're the generation that's going to
instantiate the daily in the form of
computational entity as well.
That's right.
I mean,
Kurzweil even as a funny line about
that,
is there a god?
Well,
if there's going to be pretty soon,
as soon as we hit the singularity
singularity assignments and it reminds
me of what I was religious.
You know,
I used to be an evangelical.
I went to Pepperdine University,
which is a Church of Christ school.
I was really into it and uh,
and going to church and all that stuff,
and I,
I go to the singularity summit.
I was like,
wow,
I'm back in church.
Here's Ray Kurzweil grew up there
telling us we are the first generation
that will live forever and you know,
operate a gray,
this radical life extension.
The scientist,
you know,
he,
he's on record saying the first person
to live a thousand years is born now.
Is this alive now?
Right?
So there's two elements to the heaven
issue that we can discuss them.
And one is the belief in the existence
of heaven and the other is the positing
of heaven as an Ame.
Yes,
those are interestingly related.
So from my perspective from.
So one of the things as far as I'd been
able to tell,
one of the things that allows us to
transform the reality that's too
complicated to perceive into these
functional low resolution icon.
So let's say is the name have to aim
right and you have to aim with your
eyes.
In fact,
we're also extraordinarily good at
detecting how other people aim with
their eyes.
So the question is always,
well,
where should you a?
And then the answer to that archetype,
I would say biologically for that
matter,
is that you should aim up because why
the hell would you aim down?
Down is hell,
right down is where the suffering is,
down is where the malevolence is,
so you aim up and architecturally op is
heaven.
And so one of the things that I can't,
it seems to me that there's some
possibility that it was impossible for
human beings to discover the future,
which is something that we seem to have
done.
Maybe that was prefrontal extension
ended.
That was the expansion of the prefrontal
cortex and its deep wiring with the
visual cortex that actually enabled us
to foresee the future.
Something like that.
I don't know if you can foresee the
future without,
without stumbling upon the idea of
heaven at the same time because having
that sense becomes the best possible
future and you're aiming at,
you're aiming at a better future and
because you're ending out a better
future,
you're kind of compelled to also
conceptualize,
at least in principle,
like the platonic ideal of the future.
And so then that future potential starts
to become a kind of a reality,
something like that.
Yeah.
I think that's a super good point.
My,
again,
my concern about obsessing too much
about the next life is you're going to
miss out on this life,
which is where you live right now.
Uh,
but,
but that's different from aiming at it.
I mean,
my,
I wrote a book on moral progress,
the moral arc,
you know,
aiming for incremental improvements in
civil rights,
health and longevity and,
and,
and ridding ourselves of disease and
war.
These are all admirable goals and we
should keep doing that aiming for
something.
And I do like the metaphor of it is,
maybe it's because we're a social
hierarchical species.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that's why the pyramids.
I believe that.
I think that's what the pyramids
represent with her,
with her gold cap,
right?
It's
right.
And uh,
and the Washington monument is the same
thing,
right?
Or The pyramid of hierarchy of needs and
so on.
At the end of my chapter on,
on a model theisms versions of Heaven,
I float the idea.
I probably won't be accepted by
evangelicals and fundamentalists,
but that was,
you know,
when Jesus talked about the kingdom is
within,
you mentioned this,
not as not as often as I would've liked,
but I think he's referring to the fact
that heaven is within us in the sense
that we should be aiming to improve
ourselves.
And you know,
that Christians have an atheist of
conflicted over this passage where he
says,
uh,
you know,
Matthew Sixteen,
Twenty six,
I say unto you,
there are some standing here which will
not taste death until they see the son
of man coming in his kingdom and,
you know,
of course atheist,
ha,
he's still not here.
Uh,
but,
but what if he meant something else that
happened is not a place to go,
but a way to be here.
And now I'm
very,
I'm very,
what would you call?
I'm not so viewpoint that I think is
very much worth pursuing.
I would also.
But I also think there's something
deeply strange about that too,
because
I think that if a psychological state
becomes profound enough,
it starts to become a social state.
And so I would say that that,
that Kingdom of God that's within,
which is something tolstoy wrote a lot
about,
by the way,
that was a book that he wrote,
a book called the Kingdom of God is
within us and that profoundly influenced
Mahatma Gandhi by the way,
and they had lengthy correspondence
which was part of the reason that Gandhi
became an unknown.
Use nonviolent resistance,
right in his fight against the English.
It's was quite interesting,
but I think that there is.
There is
there.
It's something like this.
Maybe when you go to a concert,
it's a great concert and you're having a
very profound psychological experience
of unity and harmony,
which of course is what you get into
concert,
but if the experience is profound enough
psychologically and individually,
it also starts to encompass and envelop
the people around you.
And so I think the Kingdom of God that
Christ was talking about with something
like this is why I like jumped piaget so
much.
It's something like the pig and
equilibrated state where things are
working out really well for you when
you're deeply immersed in a meaningful
experience.
But at the same time,
that meeting is structured so that it's
maximally beneficial for the people who
are immediately around you and for the
people who are distantly related to you.
And so everything stacks up and some
that's some.
That's something like the idea of the
ladder to have under the stairway to
heaven today.
Everything stacking up properly.
And then there's a.
see,
I think when people experience that,
and this is where the metaphysics
touches the material.
I think that when people.
Yes,
exactly that precisely dot yes,
precisely that.
Well,
did you notice that the demons are
upside down going down,
right?
Which is exactly right.
That's exactly the right way to
conceptualize it.
So I think that when people have an
experience of that stacking of meaning,
that they also have an intimation of
immortality that goes along with that,
that's embodied.
And that that's partly why the
metaphysical speculations about the
reality of the Kingdom of Heaven,
there'll be merged because it's not just
conceptual right there.
There is embodied experience and people
report the same thing when they have
transcendental experiences of various
sorts and those.
And we know from a scientific
perspective that those can be very
reliably induced with the use of agents
like psilocybin and you know,
I've been really fascinated by what's
been happening at Johns Hopkins Hospital
with the Psilocybin experimenters
because one of the most recent things
they showed was that if you take people
dying of cancer and you give them
psilocybin and they have a mystical
experience,
which is something like an experience of
the Kingdom of God on earth,
but also eternally at the same time that
they lose their fear of death or that at
least it's much modified.
You know,
that's a hell of a finding.
That's really.
You can't just,
you can't just walk away from that
easily because that's a hell of a thing
to,
to treat.
Well,
I have a chapter on that in heavens on
earth,
on near death experiences.
Um,
and so,
but we're talking about two different
things.
Um,
you know,
the,
the transitioning from life to death in
the most pain free or anxiety reduced
state is more progress,
you know,
medical progress,
psychological progress or whatever.
And I'm all for Psilocybin,
does it or whatever.
Then great,
we should do that,
but there's a lot of people that claim
more than that,
that this is opening the doors of
perception into another world.
It's actually out there and that those
of us who have not taken acid,
we just simply can't know.
So now we now we get at this question of
truth.
You know,
it's one of my columns and scientific
American and I recently wrote called
what is truth anyway?
I mean when I say like I prefer dark,
dark chocolate and you prefer milk
chocolate,
you know,
there is no truth.
That is to be discovered.
Years is true for you mind street for me
or I say stairway to heaven is the
greatest rock song of all time and you
say,
no,
freebird is better than stairway to
heaven.
And we argue about that,
but there's no,
there's no experiment we're going to
run.
And so as we start to move along these
lines,
like when Deepak Chopra tells me
meditation works,
okay,
so if it works for you or it doesn't
work for me,
okay,
those are still in that state of
internal truths.
But what we want to know in sciences
doesn't work for everybody,
or 67 percent of people that do an hour
of meditation a day under these
conditions have reduced stress hormones
and blood pressure and so on,
in some measurable way that's different
than just an internal state.
So,
um,
when we're talking about,
again,
just working on Torque for striving to
better ourselves or some kind of heaven,
if you mean just,
you know,
metaphorically so that I can better
myself.
That's different than there's an actual
place you can go to a that's going to be
there after we die.
And so I think this is where scientists
go on way.
You also start messing about with the
idea of place in a way that,
that that's the problem with having
discussions about fundamental realities
and know when you said another thing
that Christ said was the Kingdom of
Heaven is spread upon Earth.
But men do not see it and that's,
that's something that's akin to the idea
of the Kingdom of God is within you,
although it's.
It's a strange twist on it because it
also adds an element of externality or
physicality to it and an element of
immediacy.
Not something that's forestalled into
the future,
but I wonder,
see,
in my wild or moments of speculation,
I have this notion that if things stack
up properly,
so imagine that you're immersed in a
very deeply meaningful experience and
and it's,
it's operating.
It's indicating that harmony has been
established between multiple levels of
being simultaneously.
I wonder if that can.
I wonder if that can put you in a place
that's profound enough or deep enough so
that the structure of time and space,
it still starts to warp around that.
I mean,
I know that that's A.
I can't formulate that well,
but there's something.
There's something about it that seems to
me to be correct about that because
people have intimations of immortality
and they have intimations of,
of,
of heavenly and hellish abodes as well,
and they're not,
they're not.
They're not the simple kind of
irrational,
even rational fundamentalist beliefs
that often people talk about when
they're discussing religious belief.
There are more reflected in direct
experience and it's not easy to make
sense of them.
Well,
when you delve into the literature on
Judaism,
Christianity and Islam and their
versions of the afterlife and heaven,
they're quite different and the Jews are
far less obsessed with going some place
after death.
In fact,
originally they had,
they were going,
no place at all.
Show was just nothing.
It was just he returned to where you
were before you were alive,
just no place,
uh,
and so,
so that,
that religion is far more focused on the
here and now we have a moral duty to
help people,
the poor and so on now and to live
better lives and more lives of dignity
and honor and now and Christianity
really started off more like that.
Then kind of morphed over the centuries
and particularly in fundamentalist and
evangelicals in the 20th century toward
this place we're to go
after we die.
Yeah.
You kind of had the schism in
Christianity today between the kind of
the fundamentalists that are constantly
talking about the afterlife and
accepting Jesus and they're focused on
missionary,
working in diverting people versus say
maybe the Rick Warren's of the world
that want to put their money into a soup
kitchens and helping the poor and,
and,
and Christians have a moral duty to help
those in need and not so much focused on
the next life.
It's funny.
Yeah,
because there,
there are real dangers associated with
both those kinds of conceptualizations
mean you alluded to one danger that was
associated with,
let's call those who are concerned more
with the immediate present.
And that's the,
that's starting to manifest itself in
these,
in these,
um,
technological,
immortal,
immortalists.
They're saying,
well,
we should transform the nature of being
extraordinarily radically right here and
now so that we have heaven in the
mortality here.
You think,
well,
what do we lose by doing that?
You know,
and that's a question that's worth
asking because if we're trans human,
then we lose being human.
And it may be that we actually don't
want to lose being human,
even though being human means suffering
and malevolent,
something like that.
It's a very hard question.
But then the Christians,
this is what we're.
She went after the Christian since it's
such an hour.
He said,
well,
if you despise the current world and you
leave everything to be rectified in the
afterlife,
then you just abandoned life itself and
you're really traders to life.
And so how,
how does steer through those to shoot
two shows,
let's say is thing or to cliff's.
That's a very difficult proposition.
Well,
it's my message in the book to,
to the military and the cryonics and
transhumanism and so on is I'm glad
you're working on this problem,
you know,
because,
or don't you want to live to be a
thousand years?
And my response is look,
just get me to 90 without cancer and 100
without Alzheimer's on 110 without being
plugged into machines and lying in a
bed.
Because that's not a life.
And so and so I'm glad people are
working on like,
what's the best diet?
How much?
What can we do to improve our memory and
so on.
That's all great and I'm glad and I'm
glad Kurzweil is now the chief engineer
of all Google.
I mean he's got some resources to do
something about this,
but that this focus on living a thousand
years,
your first one,
you may miss that little incremental
things we can do,
but also you're missing out now.
There's this fell on my right about in
the book I'm on Ray Kurzweil.
It's a little kind of biographical film
of him.
I'll transcendent man and he's
constantly talking about,
you know,
living forever and so on and he's
obsessed with his father.
His father died when he was 51,
father was 50 ones and and ray was kind
of missed out having a father figure
because the father was always working
and Ray was a real entrepreneur achiever
from his teenage years,
so he was always working and the film
kind of follows him around collecting
everything he can about his father and
he keeps it in the basement of his house
and he wants to resurrect his father and
a computer and it's like,
Whoa,
boy.
Freud would have a field day with this
guy,
but there's something,
there's something going on there.
This sort of rose focus on.
I see this.
This is strange dichotomy and attitude
that you just described.
Even characterizing use that in my own
life because I'm very interested in
technologies that stave off aging,
dietary manipulations,
and I have this machine in my basement
that's intense pulse light,
late intense pulse light machine that's
unbelievable skin rejuvenator like it's
an absolute miracle.
This machine.
And it'll take,
it'll take sun damage from your skin
completely.
And,
and force rejuvenation.
It's like,
it's like using photoshop on your skin.
It's amazing.
And,
but,
um,
and so I think,
well,
isn't it interesting to do everything
possible to prolong youth in life?
But at the same time there's another
part of me that's thinking,
well,
this is something I wrote about it in
this new book that I'm publishing.
I'm just thinking about socrates and his
ability to accept his death.
Knowing what socrates seems to have
revealed in his acceptance of his death
was that if you live your life properly,
then you,
you've maybe you've lived your life in
some sense,
you've exhausted it in some sense.
The question is if you,
if you live the thousand years,
well,
what exactly what,
what exactly would you do?
You know,
like,
I've had kids and I loved having kids,
but I wouldn't have them again.
Like I wouldn't do that again,
I don't think.
And I have a grandchild and that's fine,
but that's a new thing.
Like I've had a career and I,
as I get older,
the idea of having 10 more careers
seems.
It's not like I'm not interested in it,
but it doesn't grip me the same way that
it would have,
say 20 years ago.
And so I wonder,
like I wonder if it is the case that
life is in some sense structured so that
its finitude as necessary and not
something that should be
well casually transcended.
Let's say.
Well,
the transhumanists would respond to
that,
uh,
that you're just used to this idea of
only living 80,
90 years.
And then you're done,
uh,
that we would adjust to that.
Well,
maybe
the question would be who would be the
weed that would adjust to that?
Yes,
he would no longer okay to get there.
We would no longer be human there.
The idea of the transhumanist
singularitarian people is,
is truly,
you're not human anymore.
We have brain,
like the cochlear implant for hearing is
a kind of brain transplant device.
Well,
they want to ramp that up and put in
your cortex and you'd hit,
sent centrally,
have wikipedia in your brain and for
instant access and,
and that it would truly bring new
meaning to what it means to be human.
You could also argue that that's a form
of death because if you transform
yourself so radically that you're
unrecognizable,
then what?
Where's the continuity with what you
once were?
You know,
this was one of the reasons I have some
real sympathy for many reasons.
I have many reasons for this,
but one of them that I have very much
sympathy for.
The idea,
the Christian idea,
that's that's associated with the
mortality of the resurrection of the
body because the Christians insisted
that this is not some sort of abstract
lights like it's.
It's not uploaded into a computer.
It's not blowing out all of your
limitations.
Now you know,
you might ask what the resurrected body
would be and of course that's a
particularity.
That's a perfectly fine question,
but it doesn't.
It doesn't.
It's
that doesn't move you around.
The fact that there was a question that
was really to be grappled with there
because what the Christians were trying
to do was to have their taken either to
in some sense and to say,
look,
there's some absolute utility to the
limitation that is imposed upon you by a
mortal frame.
Right?
That's the characteristic element of
being human and that perhaps there's a
way of having that in transcending it.
At the same time.
Now what that would look like is
obviously vitamins,
deal with that and heavens on earth to
have a chapter on the soul and post
descartes.
Christians became more doulas before
that.
They were more focused on the physical
resurrection of the body.
There are still some Christians today
who think that they'll physically be
resurrected,
but most of them,
most of them are journalists and it's
just,
it's just this kind of nonphysical thing
that goes and,
and be and is with God and Jesus and so
on.
Uh,
but,
you know,
they actually debate this
question of identity.
The problem with identity.
He said,
well,
if you're physically resurrected in
heaven,
what's,
what's there?
How old are you get?
And some of them actually have an
answer.
You're 30,
you know,
that's like the ideal age physically,
I suppose mentally and also Jesus was 30
and it's
maybe okay.
So,
but,
but then the question is,
is an,
I asked this question for the mindup
loaders,
the transhumanist,
it's like there is no fixed,
first of all,
all your cells in your.
And almost all of the atoms in your body
are recycled about every decade or so.
So there is no defined physical self of
you.
You know,
the thesis ship,
you replace all the wood and the ship,
we still call it,
of structure.
That was Schrodinger's Turret,
right?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So it's the pattern of information that
is your memories,
your memory cells,
memory cells.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
That's better.
But at what age?
You know,
because I have memories now that I
didn't have when I was 30,
so what happens if I'm resurrected at
age 30,
whereas all the memories of my last.
I'm 63 now,
so as 33 years of memories,
I want those too.
And so does the.
Okay.
You can have all those memories but
wait,
the memories I have now at 63 of when I
was 30 are very different than the
memories when I was 30 of what I was
like at that time.
And so there is no fixed set of memories
even that represents you because those
are constantly edited and changed and
it.
And it's like,
okay,
now I understand when I had that 10
years as a bike racer in the 19
eighties,
I,
you know,
I was just sort of going through and
doing my thing and now I see in context
what that meant for my life.
But I didn't know it at the time.
That's true for everything we do.
That's why I was laughing.
People write memoirs in their twenties
or thirties.
It's like,
how can you write a memoir?
You don't have no idea what you're doing
now is going to be in 30 years.
And so in religious.
So both,
both scientific attempts at immortality
or the afterlife or whatever.
And religious,
they have the same problem.
Uh,
you know,
what is up there that's been resurrected
because there is no fixed self.
It's a constantly dynamic changing
system.
And then there's one more problem.
That idea with the point of view,
self appeal of these cells.
You know,
there's,
you and I looking out through your eyes
and Jordan go to sleep tonight.
You wake up tomorrow morning and you're
groggy for a few minutes,
but,
but your,
your point of view returns and you know,
the singularity people,
they think,
well,
we'll copy all your memories and put
them in a computer and then we'll turn
it on and you'll wake up and you'll,
you'll be looking out through the little
camera hold.
They're like Johnny Depp in
transcendence.
And you'll be in there.
No,
I don't think so.
Why would your point of view all of a
sudden leap from your current body into
the computer in the same sense that
instead of sacrificing your brain and
slicing it up and scanning,
this is the current thoughts scanning
every synapse.
What if in a hundred years from now,
we had a sophisticated MRI machine that
could scan your brain and scan every
single synapse and reproduce it,
and we had a computer big enough with
Moore's law doubling and so on.
It would be enough to just reproduced
your entire connectome and turned it on
you,
Jordan Peterson.
He's still standing there right next to
the computer and they turn it on.
You're not all of a sudden on computer.
Well,
there's other problems with that too,
is that,
you know,
if I remember correctly,
you have more neurons in your autonomic
nervous system then you have in your
central nervous system.
Well,
the
brain isn't in your head,
not just your brain.
No.
So you haven't extended buddy,
so you to the chronic biotics people,
they love up the head.
We're just going to clone your butt.
Okay.
This is getting too complicated.
You really need the whole body.
Yes.
Well that's.
That's the physical resurrection issue
is that the idea that,
and I think that you put your finger on
the flaw in,
in the,
in the new way more tap in the new
immortality crowd.
You know,
they think if they really are
Cartesians,
they think of your consciousness is
something that's.
Well,
they're confused about it in some
because they think of it as a kind of
soul,
which would be a pattern and that
pattern is only instantiated in the
brain.
It's like,
oh,
physiologically that's just not the
case.
It's like,
what about the hormones?
What about.
There's a lot of things going on in the
brain that aren't easily reducible to
synaptic patterns,
especially when you consider also its
connection with the body and you have to
consider that.
It's so good.
Even worse than that,
because not only are we all of those
things,
we are also social beings and so there's
all the interactions we have and have
had with all the other people in our
lives or neighbors or strangers or
whatever,
so you have all those binary digits that
have to be captured of all the
interactions going back in your whole
life,
not just your life,
but all of the social,
cultural,
political,
economic forces that have been grinding
along for centuries that shape who we
are and the kind of world we live in.
You know,
if you're going to create a virtual
reality,
a holodeck that regrade saw that,
you know,
I mean this would be a huge computer.
Essentially.
It would be the universe is what you
would need.
What we ended up with a map that's just
as big as the territory.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
It's a big problem.
You wrote a book about that.
That's going to fold it up.
Where are you going to put it?
That's the big
like that Steven Wright line about.
I got a map of the United States.
Actual size.
Yeah.
It's really hard to fold up.
Exactly.
So,
oh,
so let me ask you a couple more personal
questions if you don't mind.
Now you,
you mentioned,
um,
briefly during our,
during our conversation that you know,
you,
you were,
you're from a pretty fundamentalist
Christian background and you became a
skeptic and you've been pursuing that
with,
with well adamantly,
let's say for a very long time.
So two questions is what,
what put you on that path and what do
you think your positive function as a
skeptic is?
Yeah,
so first of all,
my family wasn't religious at all.
They weren't antireligious to just
wasn't a thing.
I became interested in it in the early
seventies when I was in high school,
which was sort of the early development
of the Evangelical Movement,
the United States.
So I called born again movement and
there was no affiliation with any church
or particular.
We all recognize that organized religion
was probably not great.
So just sort of a one on one.
It's just you and Jesus and the Bible,
you and God and so on.
And uh,
that was that whole Jesus Christ
superstar.
Timing and all that,
but I took this really seriously and I
went to pepperdine and I took courses in
the Old Testament and New Testament.
I read everything cs Lewis wrote to the
course in the writings of Cs Lewis,
but I was into it then.
You know,
at pepperdine you're in the bubble of,
you know,
the Christian worldview is totally
consistent.
It's internally coherent,
uh,
until you're outside the bubble.
So when I went to a secular university
and to study experimental psychology,
not only was that more of a grounding in
the scientific method of understanding
reality,
but just for fun.
I took courses in,
first of all,
I took courses in evolutionary theory.
I was kind of a creationist.
I remember sitting there thinking,
Holy Shit,
this stuff is real.
But then I took a course in anthropology
and comparative mythology and that kind
of opened up my eyes.
So I sort of went through my Joseph
Campbell stage and,
and the myth of the hero.
I read the hero of a thousand faces and
all that.
It's like,
okay,
this is,
this is a different way of looking at
things than,
than pure scientific way,
but it's also different from a lot of
these religious traditions,
you know,
so that,
that's sort of told me that the
particular religion I was in a wrong to
ask is that,
is it right or wrong?
It's just,
it's a completely different thing and it
just wasn't working for me anymore.
So I enjoyed the scientific way of
thinking about the world and I was
surrounded by people that it's not that
they were atheists in graduate school
and after that it's like,
remember,
this is now the late seventies.
And then when I went to graduate school
in the second time for my phd in history
of science of late eighties,
um,
again,
the whole eighth science,
religion,
atheist,
atheism,
that wasn't a thing.
No one really talked about it.
It wasn't like a big thing you have to
decide.
Say,
are you at the eastern atheist?
No one really talked about that.
And so my focus is really on this
science and understanding things.
Now the problem with being a sort of an
intellectual historian of science
psychologists like I am,
and you're interested in study in
beliefs like I do.
Um,
and then also being a public
intellectual is the publisher of skeptic
magazine.
And I write this column for scientific
American every month I got to
essentially debunk something or analyze
something is it kind of puts you in this
role of like,
well,
I got to say if this is right or wrong,
this is true or false or,
or something in between.
So I,
I'm,
I'm constantly on this kind of razor
edge between,
I just am curious observer of people's
beliefs.
And then on the other hand,
I have actually have to pass judgment
and writing every month.
Well,
is this one correct or not correct?
Or something in between them.
Um,
and uh,
some might,
again,
it's at that different levels.
You know,
sometimes I'm just talking about
people's beliefs.
Other Times I'm at,
I'm actually kind of forced to say,
well,
I think this is probably true.
We're probably not true.
And,
uh,
and I think this is,
you know,
I listened to,
I tried to listen to that first podcast
you do with Sam,
so difficult to get through again to me,
you know,
two hours,
you were just talking past each other at
different levels of Sam's laser focused
on,
you know,
people behave,
they act on certain beliefs and the
obvious one flying planes into buildings
is because you have a certain belief
that leads to that,
yes,
that's true.
And it would be good if people didn't
believe these things that lead them to
do those kinds of violent acts.
Uh,
but there's a whole nother level you can
talk about beliefs that have nothing to
do with leading to violence or so on and
so to.
It just depends on what's your goal when
you're talking about this particular
thing right now.
Uh,
and,
you know,
so I,
I'm good friends with Stephen Jay Gould
and you know,
I was sympathetic to his noma
in the sense that the world's already to
tribal.
And so if we can calm everybody down,
that's good.
On the other hand,
I do think science and reason Kennan
form and maybe even in some cases
determined human values and moral
decisions,
right and wrong and so on.
I've written quite a bit about that too,
and so again,
that's sort of a different level of what
you're talking about and what the goals
are at that particular moment.
Yeah,
well,
I mean the skeptic when,
when,
when I think of a skeptic,
this is a strange leap of course,
but there's a scene in revelation where
Christ comes back and he comes back with
a sword coming out of his mouth and
that's where he divides the damn didn't
save and that's a.
that's also an image of the logos,
right?
The word that brings forth order out of
chaos because hardly what you do as a
skeptic.
It isn't so much that you dam the untrue
is that you rescued the truth and that's
really necessary for people because we
need to stand on a rock.
And now one of the big problems I have
with new age movement,
and I've kind of started this
technically looking at the way that
creative people think because there are
creative people who are critically
minded and there are creative people who
are not critically minded and non
critically minded.
Creativity seems more associated with
mental illness and psychopathology or
you have to be able to discriminate
between what's worth saving and what
isn't so to speak.
And that's what a good skeptic does.
Cause a skeptic isn't necessarily
someone who says,
oh,
this is all false.
A good skeptic is someone who says,
oh look,
there's a kernel of truth here,
but it's deeply buried under layers and
layers of,
of rust and nonsense that needs to be
burned away or polished away so that we
can get to what's absolutely essential.
Yeah.
So back to where you were saying before
about striving upwards towards something
that heaven up there,
whatever that is.
Um,
you know,
of course we don't want to go for utopia
because there's no such place to get to
and that causes catastrophes in history.
So.
But the idea of making the world a more
rational place,
this is a good goal and this is the kind
of thing that we do at skeptic magazine.
I know,
what do we do?
We promote science and reason and
critical thinking.
You write about critical thinking and
this is what you do.
Uh,
so we're all working on that and that.
And that's good.
Um,
sorry,
go ahead.
So when,
um,
when we talk about literature,
for example,
this return to the books of the Bible or
dusty,
see,
or if we want to make our listeners'
heads explode,
Ian Rand and Atlas Shrug.
Why have people by the tens of millions
purchased her books?
You know,
literary critics say they're awful,
they're terrible.
Novels are not well written and her
fingers are black and white.
And her philosophy is wrong.
Okay?
But ask yourself,
why do tens of millions of people love
those books?
And it's because she's doing something
else.
She's not trying to spread the world the
way it actually is,
but that the way it could be.
And these are the things we've done
wrong.
Communism,
socialism.
Because she came out of that Russian
background and so you know,
her figures like John Golf,
these are kind of ideal things to strive
for.
Yes,
exactly.
Yeah.
Well that her fingers are archetypal
heroes have a certain form.
If we could bring it back to some real
world example.
I just recently recently started
following a Jocko willink.
Now I'm never going to be Jocko willink,
but you know,
I got his book and I read one page a day
and you know,
it's kind of,
it's sort of like,
oh yeah,
yeah,
come on,
you can get up at six in the morning and
get out there on your bike riding with
the guys.
I don't want to do it.
But then I see tacos page and he's good
at it.
Okay.
So in a way it's not describing the
world in a scientific way of it's,
it's sending a different message,
like you should strive to be this,
even if you don't make it,
just do it,
do something.
Anything.
And that's a different sense of
different goal.
Yeah,
I think to that.
Okay.
So first of all,
with regards to again round,
I think the criticism leveled at her
that her characters are too black and
white is correct because I think that
one of the things that distinguishes
great literature from propaganda is that
in great literature most of the conflict
is within rather than between.
Right?
And so,
and the problem with Ayn rand is all her
good characters are the same good
character and all her bad characters are
the same bad character and,
and there's no overlap between them.
So there's a curiosity,
there's an architectural purity,
but that compromises its utility as
literature.
I would say
alternation makes his point in Gulag
archipelago where he says,
if,
if only the world,
we're simply black and white and we can
take the bad people and,
and isolate them somewhere.
But the problem is,
is you know,
we all have darkness and evil
last line between good and evil runs
down every heart that says famous
sprays.
And it was something he experienced very
deeply and is also,
it's also pride,
primordial true
analyze literature.
And this as well.
There's a body of literature,
evolutionary literary analysis in which,
um,
you know,
Pete pinker writes about this at the end
of the blank slate,
which he talks about,
you know,
what these novels,
these sophisticated novels in which the
characters are rich and deep,
you know,
they,
they have all these good characters and
bad characters,
characteristics and so on.
And,
uh,
and we can,
we can glean from that in a sense that
the novelists were ahead of the
cognitive.
This is his point,
the novelist.
We're about a century ahead of
excitement,
give scientists,
figuring out of human nature
or maybe a thousand years ahead,
modern literature anyway,
you know,
so we can,
we can gain a lot from there and not
just the rich emotional experience of
reading a good novel,
uh,
but actually teasing out this is what
some of these evolutionary literary
people are trying to do.
It's like there's certain themes that
come up over and over and over again.
Uh,
it's not totally random.
You know,
unlike the postmodernists,
there actually are a certain real
meanings that the author intended.
See,
I think the problem with the
postmodernists technically speaking,
and I thought a lot about this,
is that they got their initial criticism
right,
which is that there's an infinite number
of ways of interpreting a finite set of
phenomena,
but there isn't an,
there isn't a,
there isn't an infinite number of valid
ways of interpreting a finite set of
phenomena and that's where you get right
back into the issue of circulation of
the interpretation around these great
underlying architectural themes that are
built in,
in large part right into our biology.
I read a really interesting analysis of
the,
um,
of the symbol of the dragon a while
back,
and I can't conjure up the name of the
book unfortunately,
but his hypothesis,
which I thought was a very good one,
was that a dragon is a Metta Predator.
So it's the symbol for Predator and,
but it's more than that.
But the Predator is tree snake bird.
Because the fundamental predators have
treatwell in primates were cats,
snakes and birds.
And so what it is,
is an amalgam of all those things.
And so it's real.
Just like the category of creditor is
real,
even though snakes and cats are both in
the category of Predator and no one
says,
well,
there's no such thing as a Predator,
and then you can add fire to that for a
variety of reasons,
not least being a being I'm sure that
fire white belt,
many of our ancestors as well,
and then the additional twist,
which is the dragons also hoard gold,
so human beings,
because we're not just prey.
Animals learned that if we confronted
the Metta Predator,
we would gain as a consequence.
So there are certain channels down which
good stories go based on our,
our biological nature or evolved nature.
It's not that it's completely
deterministic in that sense.
No,
no.
It's variations on a theme I would say.
Yeah,
so that was interesting.
There was an interesting article
published,
I think it was a nature a few months ago
showing that it was very,
very high resolution brain scan and so
you know,
there's the idea of course that in the
cortex that neurons that fire together
wire together and then we learned that
the neurons are actually in cortical
columns.
So they actually have their structure,
their unit structure,
so they're not just randomly connecting
with neurons everywhere in the brain,
but what his scan showed was an
underlying super highway of building
connections so that the columns
themselves could wire into the already
existing super highways.
So it was like there was an underlying
architecture that was highly probable,
was highly probable that it would
manifest itself and I thought,
well that looks like the neural
architecture of something like an
archetype
arguments
for crown is that it would be really fun
to come back and say a thousand years
from now just to see what scientists or
scholars or talking about like of how
the brain works.
You know,
what,
what's the metaphor they're using then
that.
And they'll look back on us and go,
oh,
they thought the brain is a computer.
How
are the time we come up with a fully
material account of consciousness.
Our notion of what constitutes material
will have undergone substantial
revision.
So I do wonder if sometimes I toy with
the idea of the mysterians dino and the
mysterians.
There's certain mysteries of the
universe we will never solve.
We just,
because of the limitations that this
structure of our brain and so God free
will and determinism,
the nature of consciousness,
you know,
there's a few of these core deep
question.
So my friend,
the late great Martin Gardner called
himself a Deist,
you're probably familiar with the DSM.
It's kind of like,
well,
it's based on,
uh,
William James and,
and,
uh,
manual mumo pragmatist.
It's sort of a pragmatist philosophy.
So anyway,
Martin Martin was his longtime column
district,
Scientific American,
well,
one of the founders of the modern
skeptical movement.
He was as skeptical as I am,
maybe more on almost everything,
but he believed in God and he believed
in prayer and the afterlife and so on.
Even though he would say to fellow
skeptics,
I'm,
yes,
I think the atheist have slightly better
arguments than the theater just
slightly,
but you know,
because you can't determine one way or
the other for sure,
whether there's a god or not with
determinism,
it's okay to just practically speaking,
to just do whatever works for you.
This is the pregnancies and things.
So he said,
he says,
he prays.
He believes that there is some kind of
afterlife and that there's something out
there,
not an anthropomorphic God or anything
like that.
So he called this fideism anyway,
so I kind of respected that because he,
he didn't make any truth claims like I
can prove this or I'm sure I'm right.
He said it's just true for me.
And you know,
that gets back to that question of what
is true,
what is truth anyway,
if that's all you're saying,
it's just true for me psychologically
true works for me.
It's really kind of the end of the
conversation,
but you know,
so when I deal with creationists,
I think the earth is 10,000 years old.
Okay.
So we have a problem.
There is a conflict,
you know,
Steve Gould,
non overlapping magisterial doesn't
apply there.
One side is wrong and one side is right
when you're talking about say the age of
the universe or the world,
but if you say,
look,
this,
this is what works for me.
Having this particular,
I'm not claiming I can prove it,
it just works for me.
Really.
Was there to say after that,
it's kind of the end of the conversation
and I do think sometimes that when we're
talking about free will and determinism,
you know,
what do you mean by these words and how
well the devil's always in the details
in hit an epistemological while we keep
kicking past.
I'm a compatiblist.
I think,
you know,
Dan Dennett,
I'm not a philosopher,
but now those kinds of arguments I think
make more sense to me.
In any case,
I have what I call the behavioral
compatible ism.
That is whatever your position is
intellectually on free will and
determinism.
It doesn't really matter because when
you walk out the door,
you're,
uh,
you,
you believed you were making choices.
This is the argument that I tried to
level at Sam Harris with regards to the
metaphysical foundations of his ethics.
It's like,
it's the same sort of thing is,
and I think Ben Shapiro just went after
him on the same grounds,
is that I don't care what you say about
whether or not you're an atheist,
atheist,
you act like you're part of the Judeo
Christian tradition.
And so you think you don't believe,
but I think you do,
but we have different definitions of
what the word believe means.
So now I'm not saying that that's
necessary the argument and all
arguments,
but it's one that needs to be taken
seriously,
especially by the more rationalistic
atheists because they don't give the
devil his due.
Now you're in a different category
because you went through the whole
Christian thing in detail and you know,
the,
you know,
the stories and you know,
the mythology and you know,
the psychology as well,
you know,
we've talked about Joseph Campbell and
people like him.
So,
you know,
that puts you in the,
in the,
in the realm of the,
I would say,
what would you say biblically and,
and on,
and a psychoanalytically informed.
Well,
again,
it depends what your goals are.
What are you trying to do?
I mean,
people like Sam and Richard know they're
laser focused on one particular thing
and they're working at so good.
Um,
and I'm,
I'm on board with that.
Uh,
I think know certain belief systems are
dangerous.
Uh,
okay.
So let it be good.
If we could correct those,
but I'm also interested in other aspects
of beliefs and um,
you know,
that's,
that's a slightly different goal.
So for example,
when I'm talking to Deepak,
no,
it's true.
Quantum physics says what it says.
Okay.
But at some level I say,
what's the actionable take home?
Why not?
Okay,
so let's say the world is completely
determined and you know,
right down to the last synaptic
connection that the particles,
whatever.
And I really have no choice.
Yeah.
But so what?
I still have to choose to go to work
tomorrow or as I tell Deepak,
you know,
my mortgage is still due next Tuesday.
So even if none of this matters or,
or it's all empty space or you know,
it's all consciousness.
So what
act in the world in a way as if I'm
making choices,
as if I'm responsible for my actions
because I am.
That's good.
That's.
Well,
I would also say in relationship to
that,
there isn't any evidence to me that
we've been able to determine how to
build a functional society without
building those axioms into the,
into the substructure of the society,
freewill and responsibility.
Maybe they don't exist,
but if we don't build societies that
assume they exist,
the society's become unstable
unbelievably rapidly.
And to me that's a kind of evidence they
do exist.
I mean even knowing the say game
theoretic model of a tilting the
incentives to get people to do this
versus that,
you know,
a libertarian paternalism,
Dick Taylor calls it,
you know,
so if you give people a choice
architecture where you put the desert,
you know,
in the back and in the healthy fruit
foods in the front or you have different
kinds of structured menus to get to
nudge people to choose healthier diets
or better investment tools that
companies,
things like that.
We're already doing these sorts of
things as if we can,
if not determined people,
people's actions and choices,
but at least shape them in a way.
But,
but even doing that,
we're actively choosing to do that.
So being self aware that I know that if
I go shopping on an empty stomach,
I'm very,
I'm much more likely to buy unhealthy
foods,
cookies or ice cream or whatever.
Then I would,
if I went shopping on a full stomach,
so I choose to alter my environment
around me because I'm going to nudge
myself in another direction.
How is that not a kind of a choice and
if you're a determinist to determine
determinants,
I would say.
Um.
Okay.
Do you recognize say that the addict who
is just totally hooked on heroin or acce
coat on or something is different from
Uni who are not addicted and yes,
there's a difference.
Okay.
What's that difference?
If it's all determinism,
it's tumors all the way down or
whatever.
Um,
what is the difference then between the
addict and the addict is more
determined?
No,
but I to good objection.
That's what is that as a concept?
Yeah.
What does that mean?
More determined,
right?
Exactly.
That's why I like Dan dead.
It's idea of the degrees of freedom.
You and I have more degrees of freedom
that our dogs are dogs more than the
cockroach,
whatever.
Um,
there's just more variation and we have
one additional
we're aware of in terms of time as well,
you know,
if you're,
if you're driving,
here's a nice way of thinking about the
relationship between free will and
determinism.
Let's say you're driving down the road
at 60 miles an hour.
Where do you look?
And the answer isn't right in front of
the car because you've already run over
the thing that's right in front of the
car.
So you look about a quarter of a mile
down the road.
And what that means is that you can
start to sequence your deterministic
auctions.
And so there's this idea of a ballistic
movement.
So if I do this,
let's see.
So you see I didn't hit my hand when I
came down like that.
Now,
the truth of the matter is,
is that there isn't enough time.
So when I released this movement
quickly,
there isn't enough time for the message
to get from my hand to my brain and back
to stop my hand as an element of free
choice.
I have to plan and release the entire
movement at once,
including the stopping.
That's ballistic.
And so as soon as I implement that
movement,
there is no free will.
It's like the space that have choice
over has collapsed into a deterministic
world,
but I think what we do is we look out in
the future far enough so that we can
sequence our choices and they collapse
into determinism as we implement
something like that.
And I think that works neurologically
to.
If you look at how,
how,
how action patterns actually manifest
themselves in the brain,
it does seem to be something akin to
that.
Don't make much out of the liberty
limited experiments,
for example,
well limited himself was a compatiblist
he did not believe in,
in,
in complete determinism that wears a
pink or put it this way in the blanks
slate that you are part of the causal
net of the universe,
but you're part of it and you're making
choices that further determined the
universe,
but they're still your choice so you are
morally accountable for them.
I do think the law has evolved nicely
along these lines along the,
um,
sort of shades of grey or the to know
the law if you intended to kill somebody
versus doing it in an act of a rage
because it was just on spur of the
moment.
You've got your spouse and you and you
lose your temper.
That's different from the.
If we,
we find out that for weeks you were
plotting this to kill your spouse or
whatever,
you're going to get a different kind of
penalty.
And that matches,
you know,
neuroscience pretty well.
Yeah,
I think so.
More or less control over.
So again,
more deterministic versus less
deterministic.
What are you talking about?
You're talking about degrees of freedom.
Determinist don't like the word freedom.
Okay.
Call it something else.
You have more degrees of something,
of options.
Well,
whatever you end up with as a synonym
eventually ends up meaning freedom.
Well,
I think so.
Yeah.
The word I the word.
I used the word.
So,
so that's next return.
I'm going to show your book again here,
just so that everybody remembers it and
I would like to say what were you.
Let's end with this.
What were you hoping or are you hoping
to accomplish with this book?
Apart from clarifying your own thoughts
and communicating them?
What,
what?
I mean,
you,
you've put this message into a bottle
and you've launched it out there in the
world.
What do you,
what are you hoping for?
Uh,
really to everybody,
both religious and nonreligious or
scientists.
The messages at really the here and now
is what counts more than anything else.
We don't,
again,
we live in Brooklyn,
not in 15 billion years from now that,
that,
whether or not there's an afterlife,
because clearly no one knows for sure.
We don't live in the afterlife.
We live in this life and,
and so what you do really matters how
you are in relation with other people
and your environment really matters.
It matters not just for the future but
the immediate future.
And even now,
whatever that means to you.
And uh,
so,
uh,
again,
I'm glad people are working on this and
thinking about it.
Um,
and if we can improve society
incrementally a little bit instead of
aiming for utopia,
aim for protopia.
Yep.
Yeah,
that's a great
thing.
Incremental.
And again,
instead of aiming for the mortality or a
thousand years,
let's just aim for getting more people
to 90 and 100 healthy and happy and
living fulfilled lives.
And I do talk about in the end about the
last chapter,
less pages in fact about the importance
of aiming to live a purposeful,
meaningful life.
Not a happiness.
You know,
I've
just to see the literature develop in
positive psychology about happiness.
I've read all the books,
all great,
but happiness in the sense of I'm going
to plug into the morphine drip now.
That's not what life is about.
That isn't what gets people meaningful
lives.
It's doing things that don't make you
happy,
you know,
like again,
back to your workout every day.
It's not fun.
I'm not happy working out.
Uh,
and uh,
or you know,
I was a caretaker for my parents.
Um,
I had four parents,
step parents and,
and so two of them I was a caretaker.
It wasn't fun at all.
I didn't get joy,
I wasn't enjoying it.
It was a,
you know,
an uncomfortable experience,
but it made me feel better about myself,
about the world.
Like this is what this is doing
something more deeply meaningful.
And,
and so I think that that's where it
counts actually working to make the
world a better place,
gives you a deeper,
more fulfilled life.
That is an excellent place to end.
So I think like,
I think amen to that red light for no
afterlife.
We should improve what we have right in
front of us.
Exactly.
Yep.
And that's better than happiness.
I agree.
I agree completely.
It's a much more profound orientation
and it's a boat that will tap in a
storm,
so they see,
hey,
my pleasure.
It was really nice talking with you.
Hopefully we'll get a chance to talk
again.
Your book comes out the 12 steps.
We'll we'll talk about the 12 steps.
Sounds like a fine plan yet,
but I saw your show with Dave Rubin.
I thought that was really good.
Thanks very much.
Was very good talking with you.
Alright.
Right.
Bye.